- Selamat datang kembali ke Memahami
Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum.
Nama saya John Watrous, dan
saya adalah Pengarah Teknikal untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran keempat dalam siri ini dan ia adalah pelajaran
terakhir dalam unit pertama siri tentang asas
maklumat kuantum.
Setakat ini, kita dah bincang pasal
macam mana maklumat kuantum berfungsi untuk sistem tunggal dan berbilang, kita dah tengok model
quantum circuit,
dan kita dah perhatikan beberapa
had asas dalam maklumat kuantum.
Dalam perjalanan tu, kita
jumpa beberapa konsep matematik penting
termasuk hasil darab tensor dan hasil darab dalam, dan kita akan terus
guna konsep-konsep tu dan kita akan perkenalkan beberapa
konsep baru juga bila perlu.
Dalam pelajaran ni, kita akan
fokus pada tiga contoh penting yang asas, quantum teleportation, superdense coding dan permainan CHSH,
yang juga dipanggil ketaksamaan CHSH dan tak selalu digambarkan sebagai permainan.
Ini bukan sekadar contoh rawak
yang nak tunjukkan cara maklumat kuantum berfungsi, ia betul-betul bahagian
penting dalam asas
maklumat kuantum dan
ia muncul dalam situasi yang berbeza dan kadang-kadang tak dijangka dalam maklumat
dan pengiraan kuantum.
Entanglement memainkan peranan penting dalam ketiga-tiga
contoh ni, dan sebenarnya, entanglement itulah yang buat ia berjaya
dan buat ia menarik. Jadi, pelajaran ni akan, dalam erti kata tertentu, jadi peluang pertama kita untuk
melihat entanglement beraksi
dan mula meneroka apa yang buat entanglement sangat menarik.
Gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran ni
sangat mudah, kita akan pergi satu persatu
melalui tiga contoh yang baru saya sebut,
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding, dan permainan CHSH.
Kita akan bincang pasal apa benda-benda ni dan apa yang buat ia menarik dan kita akan buat analisis yang terangkan betul-betul cara ia berfungsi
pada tahap matematik.
Sebelum kita sampai ke contoh pertama
daripada tiga contoh tu, iaitu quantum teleportation, adalah sesuai untuk kita
perkenalkan dahulu watak-wataknya,
Alice dan Bob, kalau kamu
tak kenal mereka lagi.
Alice dan Bob, adalah nama-nama
yang diberikan kepada entiti atau ejen hipotetikal dalam sistem, protokol, permainan,
dan sebarang jenis interaksi lain yang mungkin kamu nak fikirkan yang melibatkan pertukaran maklumat.
Mereka pertama kali muncul dalam
konteks kriptografi pada tahun 1970-an, tapi
konvensyen untuk guna nama-nama ni dengan cara ni dah jadi sangat biasa
dalam konteks yang lebih luas sejak tu. Ideanya adalah bahawa nama-nama ni
sangat biasa, sekurang-kurangnya di sesetengah bahagian dunia, dan ia bermula dengan huruf A dan B,
dan ia juga mudah
untuk merujuk kepada Alice dan Bob menggunakan kata ganti nama, dia (perempuan) dan dia (lelaki) semata-mata untuk ringkasan.
Kita biasanya bayangkan Alice dan Bob berada di lokasi yang berbeza dan mereka ada
matlamat yang berbeza dan tingkah laku yang berbeza
bergantung pada apa yang kita sedang bincangkan.
Sebagai contoh, kalau kita
bincang pasal komunikasi, bermaksud, penghantaran maklumat, maka kita mungkin putuskan
bahawa Alice adalah penghantar
dan Bob adalah penerima
bagi maklumat yang sedang dihantar tu.
Kadang-kadang Alice dan Bob
bekerjasama, tu sangat tipikal, tapi kadang-kadang mereka
bersaing atau mereka mungkin ada matlamat berbeza yang mungkin
atau mungkin tidak konsisten
antara satu sama lain, tapi
semua ni kena dijelaskan dalam situasi yang sedang dibincangkan.
Sudah tentu, mereka mewakili abstraksi dan tak semestinya manusia sebenar.
Kita juga boleh perkenalkan
watak tambahan seperti Charlie dan
Diane atau nama-nama berbeza yang mewakili persona berbeza seperti Eve
untuk pengintip atau Mallory untuk seseorang yang berkelakuan jahat
bergantung pada situasi.
Dalam apa jua keadaan, kita akan jumpa Alice dan Bob dalam ketiga-tiga
contoh yang akan kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran ni dan dari semasa ke semasa
sepanjang baki siri ini. Saya juga akan buat beberapa
komen tentang entanglement sebelum beralih ke tiga contoh tu.
Dalam pelajaran dua, kita jumpa contoh keadaan terbelit dua qubit ni.
Ia adalah salah satu daripada empat keadaan bell, dan boleh dikatakan bahawa
keadaan tertentu ni mewakili contoh arketipikal
bagi keadaan kuantum yang terbelit.
Kita juga jumpa
contoh keadaan probabilistik dua bit ni.
Ia serupa dengan
keadaan terbelit dalam erti kata tertentu, tapi ia tak terbelit,
entanglement adalah fenomena yang unik
secara kuantum,
pada dasarnya mengikut definisi.
Ada definisi matematik yang tepat tentang apa itu entanglement dan pada asasnya apa yang definisi tu
katakan adalah bahawa entanglement
adalah korelasi kuantum bukan klasikal.
Tapi tu tak terlalu
berguna pada tahap intuitif, ia adalah definisi entanglement dari segi apa yang entanglement bukan,
dan mungkin sebab itulah
ia memang agak sukar untuk menerangkan apa itu entanglement dan apa yang buat ia istimewa
dalam istilah intuitif.
Bila orang cuba nak
terangkan apa itu entanglement dalam istilah intuitif, kamu
sering dengar penjelasan yang sebenarnya tak
membezakan dua keadaan ni
dengan cara yang bermakna. Kamu mungkin dengar idea
bahawa kalau kamu ukur salah satu daripada dua qubit yang terbelit,
maka keadaan qubit yang satu lagi tu
WEBVTT
entah macam mana terjejas serta-merta atau keadaan dua qubit tu tak boleh digambarkan secara berasingan
atau bahawa dua qubit tu
entah macam mana menyimpan ingatan antara satu sama lain atau bahkan
mereka terikat secara emosi.
Tapi kenapa sifat-sifat tu
tak benar untuk keadaan ni?
Dua bit ni sangat berkait rapat, masing-masing ada ingatan yang sempurna tentang yang satu lagi dalam erti kata literal, tapi
ia bukan keadaan yang terbelit.
Nah, satu cara untuk menerangkan apa yang
buat entanglement istimewa dan apa yang buat keadaan ni
sangat berbeza daripada keadaan itu adalah dengan menerangkan apa yang
kita boleh buat dengan entanglement
atau apa yang kita boleh tengok berlaku
disebabkan entanglement yang melebihi keputusan yang kita buat tentang cara kita mewakili
pengetahuan kita menggunakan vektor.
Ketiga-tiga contoh
yang akan kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran ni ada sifat ni kerana ia menggambarkan
benda-benda yang boleh kita buat dengan entanglement yang tak
boleh kita buat dengan keadaan ni
atau dengan mana-mana keadaan yang berkorelasi secara klasikal.
Memang sangat tipikal dalam kajian maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum bahawa kita memandang entanglement sebagai sumber
yang membolehkan pelbagai
tugasan diselesaikan.
Dan bila kita buat tu, kita memandang keadaan ni sebagai mewakili
satu unit entanglement.
Kita merujuk unit entanglement ni
sebagai e-bit, e bermaksud
entangled atau entanglement.
Memang benar ia dua qubit, tapi sebagai kuantiti
entanglement, ia satu e-bit.
Kamu juga boleh memandang sepasang
bit klasikal biasa dalam keadaan probabilistik berkorelasi dari tadi sebagai sumber yang merupakan
satu bit kerawakan bersama.
Ia boleh sangat berguna dalam
kriptografi untuk berkongsi bit rawak dengan seseorang dengan andaian
bahawa tiada orang lain tahu apa bit tu supaya ia
boleh digunakan sebagai kunci persendirian
atau sebagai sebahagian daripada kunci persendirian, sebagai contoh, untuk tujuan penyulitan.
Tapi dalam pelajaran ni, fokus kita akan tertumpu pada keadaan terbelit ni dan
benda-benda yang boleh kita buat dengannya.
Dan sekadar untuk jelaskan terminologi, bila kita kata Alice
dan Bob berkongsi e-bit, apa yang kita maksudkan adalah bahawa
Alice ada qubit bernama A,
Bob ada qubit bernama B, dan bersama-sama pasangan A, B
berada dalam keadaan Phi plus.
Tak penting nama apa
yang kita pilih untuk dua qubit tu, sudah tentu, kita boleh
pilih nama lain, tapi sepanjang pelajaran ni,
kita akan guna nama-nama ni
demi kejelasan. Contoh pertama pelajaran
ini adalah quantum teleportation,
yang selepas ni kita akan
sebut je sebagai teleportation untuk ringkasan.
Apa itu teleportation adalah satu protokol yang membolehkan penghantar untuk
menghantar maklumat kuantum kepada penerima menggunakan hanya entanglement
dan komunikasi klasikal untuk
mencapai penghantaran tu.
Ia langsung takde kena mengena dengan tafsiran biasa
perkataan teleportation dalam fiksyen sains, iaitu bahawa jirim hilang
di satu lokasi dan muncul di lokasi lain.
Quantum teleportation hanyalah nama yang bertujuan untuk membayangkan tu sebagai imej atau kiasan.
Yang di-teleport adalah
maklumat kuantum bukan jirim, dan itu berlaku
melalui penghantaran maklumat klasikal
bersama-sama dengan entanglement.
Untuk memahami betul-betul
cara teleportation berfungsi, adalah berguna untuk bermula dengan
menyediakan pentas, boleh dikatakan.
Apa yang kita akan buat adalah bayangkan senario yang melibatkan Alice dan Bob dan
senario tu adalah seperti berikut,
Alice ada qubit bernama Q yang
dia nak hantar kepada Bob, bermaksud dia
nak Bob pegang dalam tangannya
sebuah qubit yang berada dalam keadaan yang sama
dengan keadaan Q ketika mereka mulakan protokol tu.
Dalam erti kata lain, kita sedang bercakap tentang masalah asas
penghantaran maklumat atau komunikasi.
Kita ada penghantar bernama Alice
dan penerima bernama Bob dan Alice nak hantar
maklumat kuantum dalam bentuk qubit kepada Bob.
Ada satu kekangan, iaitu Alice tak dapat
menghantar Q kepada Bob secara fizikal, semua yang dia boleh buat adalah hantar maklumat klasikal kepada Bob.
Alice dan Bob juga ada
sumber tambahan, iaitu mereka berkongsi e-bit.
Jadi itulah senarionya, mudah nak bayangkan situasi di mana kekangan bahawa
Alice tak boleh menghantar Q secara fizikal
kepada Bob adalah abstraksi yang munasabah.
Kalau Alice dan Bob berada di
benua yang berbeza contohnya, atau kalau Alice tak tahu
lokasi tepat Bob, maka menghantar qubit secara fizikal
mungkin agak mencabar.
Tapi komunikasi klasikal
sudah tentu bukan sahaja mungkin tapi agak murah
dalam keadaan tu.
Kini, seseorang mungkin bertanya sama ada mungkin untuk Alice dan Bob menyelesaikan tugasan ni tanpa perlukan pun e-bit yang dikongsi tu.
Dalam erti kata lain, adakah ada
cara untuk menghantar qubit menggunakan komunikasi klasikal
sahaja?
Jawapannya tidak, tak mungkin untuk menghantar maklumat kuantum menggunakan komunikasi klasikal sahaja, dan itu tak terlalu sukar untuk dibuktikan
menggunakan beberapa teori maklumat kuantum
asas, yang akan kita tengok dalam
unit ketiga siri ni.
Buat masa ni, cara intuitif
untuk fikirkan pasal ia adalah fikir tentang teorem no-cloning.
WEBVTT
Bayangkan ada cara
untuk menghantar maklumat kuantum menggunakan komunikasi klasikal sahaja,
tapi komunikasi klasikal
boleh dengan mudah disalin dan disiarkan, jadi tu bermakna
komunikasi klasikal
boleh disiarkan kepada dua
penerima, Bob dan Charlie, katakan.
Kalau mereka berdua terima
maklumat klasikal yang sama daripada Alice, maka
adakah mereka berdua-dua akan dapat Q?
Tu menunjukkan yang kita telah klon Q, tapi kita tahu itu mustahil.
Sekadar sebagai sampingan, jom
perhatikan bahawa memang mungkin untuk menerangkan
vektor keadaan kuantum menggunakan maklumat klasikal.
Setiap vektor keadaan kuantum
yang akan kamu tengok dalam siri ni sedang diterangkan kepada kamu
menggunakan maklumat klasikal yang dihantar kepada apa jua
peranti yang kamu tengok tu.
Secara umum, kita boleh bayangkan
menerangkan keadaan apa pun yang ada pada Q menggunakan bit klasikal
mungkin dengan ketepatan tertentu,
tapi itu bukan komunikasi kuantum, itu hanyalah menerangkan
keadaan kuantum sebagai vektor, dan kita akan kembali ke
perbezaan antara mereka
sebentar lagi.
Kembali ke senario tadi, dan bekerja di bawah andaian bahawa Alice dan Bob memang berkongsi e-bit, kita akan
lihat bahawa Alice dan Bob
ada semua yang mereka perlukan
untuk menyelesaikan tugasan tu, dan itulah yang protokol quantum
teleportation buat, khususnya menggunakan dua bit
komunikasi klasikal.
sebelum masuk ke
perincian ni, biar saya buat beberapa komen ringkas
hanya untuk pastikan andaian-andaian tu jelas.
Pertama, kita
mengandaikan di sini bahawa keadaan Q tak diketahui oleh Alice dan
Bob, jadi khususnya,
Alice tak boleh hantar Bob penerangan
tentang keadaan Q kerana dia tak tahu secara umum.
Kita juga kena pertimbangkan kemungkinan bahawa Q berkorelasi dengan sistem lain, termasuk kemungkinan
bahawa ia terbelit
dengan sistem lain dan
penghantaran qubit ni kepada Bob mesti mengekalkan korelasi-korelasi tu.
Akhirnya, saya sebut
teorem no-cloning tadi bila saya bercakap tentang
percubaan untuk menghantar qubit secara klasikal, tapi
ada hubungan lain di sini
dengan teorem no-cloning, iaitu jika Bob
menerima penghantaran qubit Q daripada Alice,
maka dia tak boleh ada lagi
kerana Q tak boleh diklon, dan tu hanya sesuatu yang perlu diingat
apabila kita pertimbangkan protokol teleportation ni.
Protokol teleportation
boleh digambarkan dengan cara yang agak mudah dan terus menggunakan rajah quantum circuit seperti yang kamu boleh tengok di sini.
Ia sedikit bergaya dalam
bahawa ia menggambarkan pemisahan antara bahagian Alice dan bahagian Bob, tapi selain tu, ia hanyalah
rajah quantum circuit,
semua yang di atas garisan bertitik mewakili tindakan Alice dan semua yang di bawah
mewakili tindakan Bob.
Masa mengalir dari kiri ke kanan seperti biasa, dan kita nampak bahawa kita bermula
dengan dua qubit ni di sini berada dalam keadaan Phi plus,
jadi ni adalah e-bit
yang Alice dan Bob mula dengannya.
Kita boleh letak label pada qubit-qubit tu untuk jelaskan mana satu
mana, jadi ini adalah qubit A, dan ini adalah qubit
B yang membentuk e-bit,
dan ini adalah qubit Q yang
Alice nak hantar kepada Bob.
Di sini kita mengandaikan bahawa
keadaan qubit Q ini adalah Psi, tapi sedikit kemudian kita akan pertimbangkan kemungkinan
bahawa Q terbelit
dengan sistem lain. Dan apa yang rajah tu tuntut kerana kita tulis psi di sini,
adalah bahawa circuit ini
secara berkesan memang menghantar apa jua keadaan psi yang ada
di sini di bahagian Alice ke sini di bahagian Bob,
satu-satunya komunikasi
yang kita ada merentasi
garisan antara Alice dan Bob adalah dua bit klasikal yang diwakili oleh garisan berganda di sini.
Jom kita kecilkan
rajah ni sedikit supaya kita ada sedikit lebih banyak ruang dan jom kita periksa
circuit tu dengan lebih dekat.
Saya dah terangkan
syarat awal, tapi sekadar ulasan, Alice pegang qubit A
dan Bob pegang qubit B,
di mana A dan B bersama-sama
berada dalam keadaan Phi plus, jadi itulah maksudnya berkongsi e-bit.
Alice juga ada qubit Q ini yang dia nak hantar kepada Bob, dan kita sedang pertimbangkan kes bahawa Q berada dalam keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenangnya Psi.
Kini, kita tak tahu apa-apa
tentang macam mana Alice dan Bob mendapat e-bit ni.
Mungkin mereka telah
ada ia sejak lama, mungkin mereka penciptakannya beberapa masa dulu bila mereka berada di lokasi yang sama
dan mereka telah menyimpannya
untuk kesempatan ni, tapi perincian tu tak relevan di sini.
Langkah-langkah yang berlaku seterusnya, yang mewakili
protokol teleportation itu sendiri adalah seperti berikut, dan sekadar untuk jelaskan,
langkah-langkah inilah yang
rajah tu gambarkan dan kita nak
tulisnya dalam bentuk kata-kata supaya jelas apa
yang rajah tu ungkapkan.
Alice mula-mula lakukan
operasi controlled-NOT di mana qubit Q yang
dia nak hantar kepada Bob adalah kawalan dan
qubit A adalah sasaran.
Langkah seterusnya adalah dia
lakukan operasi Hadamard ke atas Q, kemudian dia ukur
dua qubit yang dia pegang,
A dan Q terhadap
pengukuran asas piawai dan kita biarkan huruf kecil a menjadi hasil pengukuran qubit A,
WEBVTT
dan kita biarkan huruf kecil b menjadi hasil pengukuran qubit Q.
Alice kemudian hantar
dua bit klasikal tu kepada Bob dan ini adalah satu-satunya komunikasi yang terlibat dalam protokol ni dan itu ditunjukkan dalam rajah
oleh fakta bahawa dua
bit ini merentasi garisan bertitik antara Alice dan Bob,
yang boleh kamu fikirkan sebagai mewakili apa jua
jarak yang memisahkan mereka.
Selepas Bob terima bit
a dan b, dia buat dua perkara.
Pertama, kalau a sama dengan satu, maka dia lakukan operasi X
atau dalam erti kata lain, sebuah NOT gate ke atas qubit B miliknya,
dan kalau pun a sama dengan sifar, maka dia tak buat tu.
Dan pada cara yang sama,
kalau b sama dengan satu, maka Bob lakukan operasi Z
atau Z-gate atau pembalik fasa
juga ke atas qubit b dan macam
tadi, kalau b sama dengan sifar, maka dia tak buat tu.
Semua ni ditunjukkan dalam rajah di mana kita ada gate controlled-X
dan controlled-Z ini di mana kawalannya adalah
dua bit klasikal.
Kamu tak perlu fikirkan gate-gate ini sebagai gate kawalan
kalau kamu tak mahu, ini hanyalah cara yang mudah
untuk ungkapkan apa yang kita nak
dalam bentuk rajah circuit. Intinya ialah Bob kenakan
X-gate kepada qubit b kalau a sama dengan satu dan
kemudian dia kenakan Z-gate
kepada qubit b kalau B sama dengan satu.
Dan demi kemudahan kemudiannya kita boleh tulis secara eksplisit
operasi gabungan yang Bob lakukan ke atas qubit b miliknya,
bergantung kepada bit klasikal
yang Alice hantar.
Jadi itulah protokol teleportation, ia cukup mudah sebenarnya, fakta bahawa ia sebenarnya berjaya adalah perkara lain
dan walaupun analisisnya
tak terlalu rumit,
kamu tak perlu rasa kamu terlepas sesuatu kalau kamu tak nampak segera kenapa ia berjaya.
Sebab itulah kita perlu
buat analisis dan itulah yang akan kita buat seterusnya.
Untuk menganalisis protokol teleportation, kita akan melaluinya satu langkah pada satu masa untuk tengok keadaan
tiga qubit tu pada masa yang berbeza.
Kita nak pertimbangkan dahulu
kes bahawa qubit paling atas berada dalam keadaan AlphaZero tambah beta satu, di mana alpha dan beta
adalah sebarang nombor kompleks
yang menyebabkan vektor ini
menjadi vektor unit.
Ini adalah qubit Q yang
Alice cuba hantar, tapi kita tak kisah sangat apa
namanya pada masa ini.
Sedikit kemudian, kita akan
tengok situasi di mana qubit ini terbelit dengan sistem lain, tapi ini adalah titik permulaan yang baik sekadar untuk kekalkan perkara mudah
dan untuk tengok cara analisis
berfungsi dengan lebih jelas.
Kalau kita pertimbangkan keadaan
tiga qubit bersama-sama di sini pada permulaan, kita nampak
bahawa keadaan ni ada bentuk yang kamu nampak di sini.
Dua qubit pertama berada
dalam keadaan Phi plus, qubit ketiga adalah yang paling atas
mengikut konvensyen
untuk menyusun qubit yang
saya terangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, dan jadi kita ambil hasil darab tensor untuk dapat keadaan
tiga qubit bersama-sama.
Kita boleh kembangkan ungkapan ni
dengan mula-mula menggantikan definisi keadaan Phi plus dan kemudian mengira hasil darab tensor
dan kita dapat keadaan
yang kamu nampak di sini.
Ia tak selalu menjadi strategi terbaik
ngomong-ngomong, untuk mengembangkan sepenuhnya
vektor seperti ni, ia biasanya idea yang bagus untuk tunggu sehingga
kamu ada sebab yang baik untuk buat tu.
Tapi di sini kita memang ada sebab, iaitu kita nak
kira tindakan controlled NOT gate ni dan dengan menulis keadaan dalam bentuk ni,
kita boleh buat tu dengan sangat mudah.
Dan khususnya, ini adalah
keadaan tiga qubit selepas controlled NOT gate dikenakan.
Qubit ketiga adalah qubit kawalan kerana itulah yang berada
di atas mengikut konvensyen kita, dan qubit kedua,
yang berada di tengah,
adalah sasaran, jadi kita hanya
operasi ke atas ket-ket mengikutnya, kalau bit ketiga adalah
sifar, tiada apa yang berlaku,
dan kalau bit ketiga adalah satu,
maka kita balikkan bit kedua.
Kemudian kita lakukan Hadamard
gate ke atas qubit ketiga, kita boleh tulis vektor yang terhasil seperti yang kamu nampak
di sini dengan menggantikan
keadaan plus dan minus dengan keadaan sifar dan satu.
Dan kalau kita nak ada cukup
ruang untuk mengembangkan yang satu ini, kita perlu mengecilkannya sedikit dan kini, dengan menggantikan keadaan
plus dan minus
dengan definisi mereka,
membawa punca dua ke dalam penyebut, kita dapat keadaan yang kamu nampak di sini.
Dan dengan mengembangkan yang satu itu, kita dapat keadaan yang kamu nampak di sini.
Jadi, itulah keadaan tiga qubit selepas Alice lakukan dua operasinya.
Alice kemudian ukur
dan kalau kita nak analisis pengukuran tu, apa yang kita buat adalah mengasingkan vektor asas piawai
untuk sistem yang sedang diukur
seperti yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran dua, dan kalau kita buat tu dalam kes tertentu ini, inilah yang kita dapat.
Dan kalau kamu tengok
ungkapan tu seketika, ia mungkin nampak sedikit aneh kerana kini nampaknya qubit pertama,
yang merupakan qubit paling bawah
entah macam mana bergantung kepada alpha dan beta, walaupun
pada masa ini tiada komunikasi telah berlaku merentasi garisan bertitik tu,
WEBVTT
tapi itu hanyalah ilusi. Ingat bahawa skalar boleh bergerak bebas melalui hasil darab tensor, jadi sebenarnya tiada makna
di mana alpha dan beta
dikaitkan dengan qubit pertama.
Apa yang kita sebenarnya buat
di sini adalah menggunakan kurungan mengikut sifat multilineariti hasil darab tensor.
Pun begitu, itulah bentuk yang kita perlu tengok apa yang pengukuran buat, dan kita boleh nampak satu
perkara menarik terus
dan iaitu kebarangkalian empat hasil pengukuran yang mungkin adalah sentiasa seragam.
Kebarangkalian untuk ukur setiap
pasangan hasil pengukuran adalah satu per empat, jadi, khususnya,
tiada kebergantungan
sama sekali pada alpha dan beta.
Kita boleh nampak tu dalam setiap kes dengan mengira nilai norma Euclidean kuasa dua bagi
vektor mana pun yang digabungkan tensor kepada vektor asas piawai yang kita asingkan,
dan dalam setiap kes kita ada satu per empat yang kita dapat dengan mengkuasaduakan satu per dua darab nilai mutlak kuasa dua alpha
tambah nilai mutlak
kuasa dua beta, yang mana adalah satu, dan jadi kita dapat satu per empat dalam setiap kes.
Ia memang sangat penting
sebenarnya bahawa kebarangkalian hasil-hasil yang berbeza ni tak bergantung dalam apa cara pun pada qubit yang
Alice nak hantar.
Kita tak mungkin ada keadaan sewenang-wenangnya masuk di sini dan keluar di sini dan namun pengukuran mendedahkan
maklumat tentang keadaan tu.
Kalau kamu nak dapat maklumat tentang keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenangnya, kamu terpaksa ganggu
keadaan tu secara umum.
Ini adalah jadual yang menerangkan bukan sahaja kebarangkalian
hasil-hasil yang berbeza, tapi juga keadaan
tiga qubit bersama-sama
bergantung kepada setiap kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran.
Kita dapat tu dengan menormalkan vektor yang digabung tensor kepada keadaan-keadaan
asas piawai yang berbeza, tapi itu mudah dalam kes ni,
kita hanya perlu hilangkan faktor satu per dua untuk dapat vektor unit.
Jadi, apa yang kita ada segera
selepas Alice ukur adalah Alice ada dua bit rawak seragam dan itu sahaja.
Khususnya, dia tak ada lagi
keadaan asal dan dia tak ada
maklumat tentangnya, dia hanya ada bit-bit rawak.
Keadaan Bob kini memang
bergantung kepada alpha dan beta serta hasil-hasil pengukuran.
Kalau kita bayangkan sebentar
bahawa Alice belum hantar hasil-hasil pengukuran lagi
jadi Bob tak tahu apa hasil-hasil pengukuran tu,
maka dia tak dapat
dapat apa-apa maklumat tentang alpha dan beta
daripada mengukur qubit miliknya.
Empat kemungkinan
yang kita ada di sini cukup dikacaubilaukan untuk pastikan tiada maklumat
tentang alpha dan beta
yang boleh pernah diperolehi
melalui pengukuran. Tu mesti benar pada tahap intuitif kerana kalau tidak kita akan ada
komunikasi lebih laju dari cahaya.
Alice sudah pasti tak
boleh hantar maklumat kepada Bob tanpa menghantar apa-apa pun, tapi sudah tentu Alice memang
hantar hasil-hasil pengukuran
kepada Bob, jadi jom kita kembangkan jadual tu untuk tengok apa berlaku bila
Bob lakukan operasi-operasinya.
Dalam lajur ini di sini, kita ada operasi-operasi berbeza yang Bob secara berkesan lakukan untuk setiap kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran
seperti yang kita perhatikan tadi,
dan kalau kita pergi satu persatu dan kita kenakan
operasi tu kepada qubit Bob, yang merupakan yang pertama, B,
kita nampak bahawa kita dapat
hasil yang sama dalam keempat-empat kes dan hasil itu adalah keadaan asal.
Jadi, keadaan asal qubit Q telah berjaya di-teleport ke dalam B.
Kalau Bob nak namakankan semula qubit miliknya dan panggil ia Q pada masa ni, dia boleh buat tu, tapi intinya adalah kini
dia pegang keadaan asal
yang Alice ada dan sudah tentu dengan keperluan, Alice tak ada lagi.
Perhatikan juga bahawa e-bit
tu telah secara berkesan habis melalui proses ini,
teleportation ada kos
dan kosnya adalah satu e-bit dan dua bit klasikal komunikasi, dan bila protokol dah
selesai, e-bit tu dah habis.
Kita kini telah buktikan bahawa
protokol teleportation berjaya dengan betul di bawah andaian bahawa qubit paling atas berada dalam keadaan kuantum
berbentuk alpha darab ket
sifar tambah beta darab ket satu.
Tapi apa berlaku kalau
qubit paling atas terbelit dengan sistem lain seperti
salah satu qubit tambahan kita
seperti yang ada pada skrin ni? Kita mungkin nak guna teleportation
dalam keadaan seperti itu.
Mungkin Alice dan Bob sebenarnya
merancang untuk lakukan teleportation 100 kali supaya Alice boleh hantar
register kuantum 100 qubit
kepada Bob, satu qubit pada satu masa.
Atau mungkin qubit-qubit tambahan ni
langsung tak dalam milikan Alice
dan orang lain ada, mungkin Alice tak tahu
pun ia wujud.
Persoalannya ialah, adakah
teleportation masih berjaya walaupun qubit yang sedang di-teleport terbelit dengan sistem lain?
Di sini, keadaan qubit Q bersama-sama dengan
sistem tambahan yang kita pertimbangkan dinyatakan seperti yang kamu nampak di sini
di mana gamma sifar dan
gamma satu adalah vektor unit yang mewakili keadaan kuantum
sistem tambahan ni.
Kita sentiasa boleh tulis keadaan sewenang-wenangnya sistem gabungan dalam cara ni.
Kita sebenarnya tak perlu pun
alpha dan beta di sini, tapi kalau kita masukkan mereka,
maka kita boleh jadikan gamma sifar dan gamma satu sebagai vektor unit
dan itu akan buat
hubungan dengan kes yang lebih mudah yang telah kita pertimbangkan lebih jelas.
WEBVTT
Kita boleh buat
analisis yang serupa dengan yang kita dah buat, tapi di mana kita juga pantau
sistem tambahan ni.
Ia sedikit lebih tunggang-terbalik kerana kita ada sistem tambahan, tapi
ideanya adalah sama, berikut adalah ringkasan yang sangat cepat.
Ini adalah keadaan awal, ini adalah keadaan selepas
controlled NOT gate,
dan ini adalah keadaan selepas
operasi Hadamard.
Kalau kita kembangkan benda-benda ni,
kita boleh nyatakan keadaan tu seperti yang kamu nampak di sini,
itulah keadaan tepat
sebelum pengukuran Alice, dan kalau kita melalui
kemungkinan-kemungkinan sama seperti tadi
dan kita pertimbangkan apa yang
berlaku bila Bob kenakan apa jua operasi yang sepatutnya dia kenakan,
maka kita dapati bahawa memang
keadaan yang betul keluar dan protokol berjaya seperti yang dijangkakan.
Dalam jadual ni ngomong-ngomong, kita guna huruf R untuk
merujuk kepada sistem tambahan ni, dan kamu boleh nampak bahawa kita guna petua yang cukup mudah,
iaitu kita putuskan bahawa kita lebih suka, sekurang-kurangnya buat sementara, menyusun
sistem sebagai B, R, A, Q
kerana itu lebih mudah untuk menulis keadaan-keadaan di sini.
Mengikut rajah, sistem sepatutnya disusun sebagai B, A, Q, R,
tapi selagi kita jelaskan, kita boleh pilih susunan berbeza yang lebih mudah.
Pendek kata, semua yang berlaku dalam analisis ni adalah
sama dengan apa yang berlaku dalam analisis yang lebih mudah,
tapi kita ada
vektor-vektor tambahan ni, gamma sifar dan gamma satu
yang basically ikut je.
Kita selalu ada gamma sifar
bila ada faktor alpha dan gamma satu bila
ada faktor beta dan pada akhirnya,
semuanya berjaya dengan betul.
Ini sebenarnya langsung tak mengejutkan, kita ada proses fizikal yang bertindak seperti operasi identiti ke atas qubit
dalam keadaan kuantum yang sewenang-wenangnya, dan hanya ada satu
cara untuk itu boleh berlaku dan iaitu bahawa operasi tu
adalah operasi identiti.
Itu sedikit lebih mudah untuk dijelaskan menggunakan formulasi umum
maklumat kuantum, tapi intinya ialah, mengikut kelinearan,
kita sebenarnya tak perlu pun buat analisis tambahan ni.
Bila kita dah tahu bahawa
teleportation berjaya dengan betul untuk qubit tunggal dalam pengasingan, kita boleh simpulkan bahawa hanya ada
satu perkara yang mungkin
yang boleh menerangkan apa yang protokol tu buat, dan iaitu ia melaksanakan
operasi identiti di mana qubit masuk di sini
dan keluar di sini, secara berkesan bertindak sebagai saluran kuantum yang sempurna
tanpa hingar.
Sekadar beberapa komen ringkas
tentang teleportation sebelum beralih ke
contoh kedua pelajaran, iaitu superdense coding.
Pertama, saya rasa penting untuk jelaskan bahawa teleportation bukan satu aplikasi maklumat kuantum, ia adalah protokol
dan khususnya ia adalah
protokol untuk melakukan komunikasi kuantum.
Untuk teleportation
seperti yang saya terangkan ini berguna, mestilah ada sebab untuk melakukan komunikasi kuantum.
Kedua, adalah munasabah untuk berspekulasi bahawa teleportation boleh, suatu
hari, menjadi cara standard
untuk menghantar maklumat kuantum, dan khususnya satu proses yang dikenali sebagai penyulingan entanglement
mungkin berpotensi digunakan
sebagai cara untuk menghantar qubit dengan boleh dipercayai. Kalau Alice dan Bob tahu mereka
akan menghantar maklumat kuantum atau mereka
ada keperluan untuk menghantar
maklumat kuantum, maka proses penyulingan entanglement ni
boleh digunakan untuk menukar bilangan e-bit berisik yang lebih besar
kepada bilangan yang lebih kecil
daripada e-bit berkualiti tinggi yang boleh kemudiannya digunakan untuk teleportation tanpa hingar atau hampir tanpa hingar.
Ideanya ialah proses
penyulingan entanglement tu dalam erti kata tertentu tak terlalu sensitif, kita boleh terima kerugian dan
kalau ia tak berjaya,
maka kita boleh cuba lagi, sedangkan qubit-qubit sebenar yang
kita nak hantar mungkin dianggap jauh lebih berharga.
Sudah tentu, ini semua spekulasi, tapi intinya ialah ia tak susah untuk mengandaikan situasi
di mana teleportation
boleh menjadi cara yang sangat praktikal
untuk menghantar qubit.
Dan perkara terakhir
berkenaan teleportation ialah idea di sebalik teleportation dan cara ia berfungsi
adalah cukup asasi
dalam maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum, teleportation adalah benar-benar batu asas teori maklumat kuantum dan variasi-variasi
pada idea tu juga sering muncul,
ia hanya satu contoh, ada cadangan untuk
melaksanakan gate-gate kuantum yang berbeza
menggunakan teleportation, tapi
di mana keadaan awal dan pengukuran yang berbeza dipilih supaya hasilnya
adalah untuk mengenakan operasi yang dipilih
dan bukannya untuk berkomunikasi.
Contoh seterusnya adalah superdense coding.
Seperti quantum teleportation,
superdense coding adalah protokol dan apa yang dicapainya adalah pelengkap kepada teleportation.
Sedangkan teleportation membolehkan
satu qubit dihantar menggunakan e-bit dan dua
bit klasikal komunikasi,
superdense coding membolehkan
dua bit klasikal dihantar menggunakan
e-bit dan satu qubit komunikasi kuantum.
Jadi, pendek kata, superdense coding membolehkan penghantaran
maklumat klasikal dan sebabnya dipanggil superdense coding
WEBVTT
adalah kerana ia membolehkan dua
bit klasikal komunikasi dimuatkan dalam satu qubit sahaja,
tapi kita kena habiskan
e-bit untuk capai ni.
Berikut adalah penjelasan yang lebih tepat
tentang persediaan tu.
Sekali lagi, kita ada Alice dan Bob, di mana Alice adalah penghantar
dan Bob adalah penerima, dan kali ni Alice ada dua bit klasikal
yang dia nak hantar kepada Bob.
Alice boleh hantar kepada Bob satu qubit sahaja dan Alice dan Bob berkongsi
e-bit yang boleh mereka guna untuk bantu mereka capai tugasan mereka,
iaitu untuk Bob terima
dua bit klasikal tu.
Kini, dalam erti kata tertentu tugasan ni mungkin nampak kurang menarik berbanding tugasan yang
teleportation capai,
terutamanya kalau kita anggap
bahawa menghantar qubit adalah jauh lebih
sukar atau lebih mencabar berbanding menghantar bit klasikal,
yang merupakan pandangan yang cukup munasabah tapi ia memang menarik bahawa ini mungkin dilakukan.
Satu sebab ia menarik
adalah kerana ia memang tak mungkin untuk capai
tugasan menghantar dua bit klasikal maklumat ni
menggunakan satu qubit sahaja tanpa
menggunakan e-bit tu.
Kita tahu ni kerana teorem terkenal yang dikenali sebagai teorem Holevo.
Teorem Holevo adalah
lebih umum daripada ni, dan penyataan tepat
teorem Holevo adalah sedikit teknikal dan memerlukan penjelasan,
tapi satu implikasi daripadanya
adalah bahawa kamu tak boleh menghantar sebarang bilangan bit klasikal komunikasi menggunakan bilangan qubit
komunikasi kuantum yang lebih sedikit sahaja.
Kalau kamu nak menghantar dengan boleh dipercayai dua bit klasikal
maklumat menggunakan qubit dan kamu tak ada
e-bit untuk digunakan,
kamu terpaksa hantar dua qubit, jadi lebih baik simpan je bit-bit yang kamu nak hantar tu.
Sebab lain kenapa superdense
coding menarik adalah kerana hubungan pelengkap yang rapat yang ia ada dengan teleportation, dan
kita akan kembali ke ni
sedikit kemudian. Berikut adalah huraian quantum circuit bagi protokol superdense coding.
Untuk yang ni, saya tak akan
senaraikan semua langkah, sebaliknya kita akan berpegang dengan huraian rajah circuit sahaja.
Seperti yang kamu nampak, kita ada
Alice dan Bob sekali lagi, di mana Alice adalah di atas
dan Bob adalah di bawah.
Inilah e-bit yang
awalnya dikongsi antara Alice dan Bob, yang
entah macam mana telah diwujudkan sebelum protokol dijalankan.
Alice ada dua bit klasikal, A dan B, yang kamu boleh nampak di sini
dan melalui protokol yang circuit tu gambarkan,
dua bit klasikal ni
akan berakhir di tangan Bob.
Hanya ada satu qubit
yang merentasi garisan antara Alice dan Bob, dan sudah tentu tiada
bit klasikal yang dihantar,
penghantaran
dua bit klasikal itulah yang menjadi tujuan protokol ni.
Kamu juga akan perasan bahawa ia ada
tepat komponen yang sama yang digunakan dalam teleportation, kita ada controlled NOT
gate, Hadamard gate,
dan Z dan X-gate
yang dikawal oleh bit klasikal.
Namun ia disusun secara berbeza, jadi jom beralih ke
analisis untuk tengok cara ia berfungsi.
Untuk menganalisis cara superdense coding berfungsi, jom mulakan dengan menulis
asas Bell, yang sangat berada di
jantung analisis ni.
Apa yang kita akan buat adalah
pertama tengok kesan yang tindakan Alice ada
ke atas keadaan Phi plus, dan apa yang akan kita nampak adalah
bahawa Alice mengubah ini
keadaan Phi plus kepada salah satu
daripada empat keadaan Bell bergantung pada bit-bit
yang dia nak hantar.
Jadi, jom tulis jadual supaya kita boleh
pantau apa yang sedang berlaku.
Pertama, kalau A dan B keduanya sifar, maka Z-gate mahupun
X-gate tidak dikenakan, jadi tindakan Alice tak buat apa-apa,
bermakna Phi
plus dipetakan kepada Phi plus.
Kita juga boleh ungkapkan tu sebagai persamaan seperti yang kamu nampak di sini,
tiada apa yang berlaku kepada qubit Alice dan tiada apa yang berlaku kepada qubit Bob
dan buat tiada apa diwakili
oleh matriks identiti.
Kini, apa berlaku kalau A sama dengan sifar dan B sama dengan satu?
Nah, kerana B sama dengan satu, kita kenakan Z-gate dan
kita tak kenakan X-gate kerana A sama dengan sifar
dan kita nampak bahawa kesan keseluruhannya ialah Alice lakukan Z-gate.
Alice berada di sebelah kanan
kerana dia berada di atas, walaupun ia sebenarnya
tak akan membuat sebarang perbezaan dalam kes
tertentu ni, kesannya ialah
keadaan Phi plus
terpeta kepada Phi minus, yang kamu boleh agak
daripada ungkapan-ungkapan ni kalau kamu ingat cara Z-gate berfungsi.
Jadi, kita boleh tambah yang satu ni ke jadual kita, ada dua kes lagi untuk dilalui, kalau A sama dengan satu
dan B sama dengan sifar,
maka Alice lakukan
X-gate yang mengubah Phi plus kepada Chi plus, dan kalau A sama dengan satu
dan B sama dengan satu,
maka Alice lakukan Z, kemudian
X dan kita dapat Chi minus.
Jadi, jadual kita beritahu kita apa yang berlaku dalam empat kes yang mungkin dan iaitu Alice secara berkesan memilih mana satu
WEBVTT
daripada empat keadaan Bell yang dia
nak kongsi dengan Bob, dan dia bebas memilih dengan bertindak ke atas qubit miliknya sahaja
dan itu adalah aspek entanglement yang cukup menarik.
Alice kemudian hantar qubit miliknya
kepada Bob, pada masa ni, Bob pegang salah satu daripada empat keadaan Bell dan dia hanya perlu
cari tahu mana satunya
untuk pulihkan bit-bit tu.
Dan kita boleh semak bahawa
memang controlled NOT gate diikuti oleh Hadamard gate
seperti yang ada dalam rajah melakukan benda yang betul.
Saya tak akan melaluinya secara terperinci, tapi kalau kamu pilih nak buat tu, kamu akan dapati bahawa kesannya adalah
seperti yang kamu nampak di sini dalam jadual.
Satu cara untuk semak tu
adalah dengan mengira sahaja. Sebagai alternatif, kita boleh sedar bahawa kita sebenarnya telah pun
melalui ni secara terbalik
dalam pelajaran sebelumnya. Dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita
ada Hadamard gate dahulu dan controlled NOT gate kedua
dan kita nampak bahawa circuit tu
memetakan keadaan asas piawai kepada keadaan Bell dengan
tanda tolak yang mengganggu dalam salah satu kes.
Bila kita balikkan susunan gate-gate dan kita pertimbangkan fakta
bahawa kedua-dua gate ni adalah inversi mereka sendiri,
apa yang kita dapat adalah inversnya,
dan jadi apa yang kita ada dalam kes
ini ialah tindakannya pergi dalam arah yang bertentangan
dan tanda tolak boleh memilih mana-mana
pihak yang dia nak berada,
tapi selain tu, ia berada di tempatnya, dan pada masa ni
adalah jelas bahawa pengukuran mendedahkan nilai-nilai yang betul,
tanda tolak di sini tak ganggu kita kerana satu muncul dengan
kebarangkalian satu dalam kes ni, dan itulah sahaja analisisnya.
Pendek kata, Alice pilih keadaan Bell dan Bob cari tahu mana satunya.
Sekadar beberapa komen ringkas
tentang superdense coding sebelum kita teruskan; pertama, kita patut akui bahawa superdense coding
mungkin tak akan
berguna atau praktikal dalam apa ertinya sebagai cara untuk
menghantar maklumat klasikal.
Komunikasi klasikal
sangat murah dan menghantar qubit secara fizikal adalah mencabar, nak kata yang baik,
dan selagi keadaan tu berlaku, kita tak jangka ada sebarang
kelebihan praktikal sama sekali daripada superdense coding.
Tapi hanya kerana ia mungkin tak
praktikal tak bermakna superdense
coding tidak menarik.
Ia sangat menarik sebenarnya, pertama, idea asasnya adalah
benar-benar sangat asasi,
dan bila saya merujuk kepada idea asas tu, saya maksudkan idea bahawa kalau Alice
berkongsi keadaan Bell dengan Bob,
maka dia boleh memilih untuk tukar keadaan tu kepada keadaan Bell lain yang
dia pilih sendiri, dia tak perlukan bantuan Bob
sama sekali untuk buat tu.
Ini adalah contoh khusus
yang berkaitan dengan keadaan Bell, tapi ada idea asas yang lebih umum yang berkaitan dengan kebebasan yang ada pada satu pemain
untuk mengubah keadaan terbelit yang dikongsi dengan pemain lain, dan memahami betul-betul
apa kebebasan tu
adalah langkah penting dalam memahami maklumat kuantum dan kita akan nampak betul-betul cara menerangkan kebebasan tu dalam istilah yang mudah
dan elegan Dalam
unit ketiga siri ni.
Superdense coding juga
memberikan contoh konkrit tentang apa yang boleh kamu buat dengan entanglement, iaitu membolehkan dua bit klasikal dihantar
dengan menghantar satu qubit sahaja. Seperti yang saya dah sebut, ini
terbukti tak mungkin mengikut teorem Holevo tanpa entanglement.
Kita juga boleh pertimbangkan teleportation dan superdense coding bersama-sama, dan kita nampak bahawa ia mewujudkan kesepadanan
antara satu qubit komunikasi kuantum dan dua bit komunikasi klasikal.
Selagi kamu sanggup
habiskan satu e-bit, kamu boleh secara berkesan
menukar satu kepada yang lain.
Teleportation membolehkan
komunikasi satu qubit menggunakan dua bit komunikasi klasikal dan superdense coding pergi cara sebaliknya
dan membolehkan dua bit klasikal
komunikasi menggunakan satu qubit komunikasi kuantum.
Tanpa menghabiskan e-bit, bagaimanapun, kamu tak boleh mengubah
sama ada satu kepada yang lain, entanglement itulah yang
membuatkan ini mungkin.
Contoh ketiga dan terakhir
yang akan kita bincang dalam pelajaran ni bukan satu protokol tapi
satu permainan yang dikenali sebagai permainan CHSH.
Bila kita bercakap tentang permainan dalam konteks ni, kita tak bercakap tentang sesuatu yang bertujuan dimainkan untuk keseronokan atau sukan,
tapi sebaliknya abstraksi matematik dalam erti kata teori permainan misalnya.
Abstraksi matematik permainan sangat kerap dikaji dalam
ekonomi dan sains komputer, misalnya, dan ada
banyak nilai
yang boleh didapati dalam abstraksi tu, jadi permainan tak semua seronok
dalam permainan rupanya,
walaupun memang seronok nak fikirkan pasal mereka.
Dalam kes tertentu ni, apa yang kita ada adalah pada dasarnya
satu eksperimen pemikiran yang boleh digambarkan dengan
cara yang cukup intuitif sebagai permainan.
Huruf-huruf CHSH merujuk kepada pengarang-pengarang, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, dan Richard Holt sebuah kertas
1969 di mana contoh tu
pertama kali diterangkan. Mereka tak gambarkannya
sebagai permainan sebenarnya, dan ia cukup biasa
untuk merujuk contoh ni
bukan sebagai permainan CHSH, tapi
sebaliknya sebagai ketaksamaan CHSH.
Bagi saintis komputer seperti saya, bagaimanapun, ia sangat semula jadi
untuk gambarkannya sebagai permainan.
Saya dah cadangkan bahawa
abstraksi matematik permainan adalah penting dan berguna dan ada banyak kategori permainan yang berbeza
WEBVTT
yang boleh dipertimbangkan. Permainan CHSH adalah
contoh kelas permainan yang dipanggil permainan bukan tempatan.
Berikut adalah persediaan secara umum
bagi permainan bukan tempatan.
Kita ada dua pemain, Alice dan Bob, yang bekerjasama sebagai satu pasukan, jadi mereka sama-sama menang
atau sama-sama kalah.
Ini bermakna mereka tak ada
insentif untuk bertindak mementingkan diri, jadi ia pada dasarnya ekstrem bertentangan dengan permainan jumlah sifar,
yang bersifat kompetitif sepenuhnya, di sini permainannya bersifat koperatif sepenuhnya.
Ada entiti ketiga yang dipanggil pengadil.
Pengadil bukan pemain dalam permainan, tapi sebaliknya pengadil
menjalankan permainan, dan sebenarnya, kamu boleh fikirkan spesifikasi
satu contoh tertentu
bagi permainan bukan tempatan dan spesifikasi seorang
pengadil sebagai setara.
Ada kekangan yang sangat penting yang dikenakan ke atas Alice dan Bob, iaitu sebaik sahaja permainan bermula, mereka dilarang daripada
berkomunikasi antara satu sama lain.
Mereka boleh bersetuju terlebih dahulu tentang
apa jua strategi yang mereka pilih, tapi tiada komunikasi
dibenarkan antara mereka semasa permainan tu sendiri.
Kalau kamu suka, kamu boleh bayangkan
permainan tu berlangsung dalam kemudahan selamat semacam itu seolah-olah pengadil memainkan
peranan seorang detektif
dan Alice dan Bob adalah suspek yang berada di bilik-bilik berbeza di balai polis, tapi cara lain untuk
fikirkan persediaan tu
ialah Alice dan Bob terpisah
oleh jarak yang sangat jauh dan komunikasi dilarang kerana kelajuan cahaya
tidak membenarkan komunikasi
berlaku cukup cepat. Kalau Alice cuba hantar mesej kepada Bob misalnya, permainan dah berakhir masa
Bob terima mesej tu.
Cara permainan bukan tempatan
berfungsi ialah pertama, pengadil tanya soalan kepada kedua-dua
Alice dan Bob sekali gus.
Soalan Alice dilabel X dan soalan Bob dilabel Y.
Secara umum, kamu boleh fikirkan X dan Y sebagai keadaan klasikal
daripada apa jua keadaan klasikal yang kamu suka dan dalam
kes khusus permainan CHSH,
X dan Y adalah bit.
Alice dan Bob kemudian mesti berikan jawapan, jawapan Alice dilabel A,
dan jawapan Bob dilabel B,
dan sekali lagi, jawapan-jawapan ni boleh dilihat sebagai keadaan klasikal secara umum dan seperti soalan-soalan, ia
akan jadi bit dalam permainan CHSH.
Pada masa ni, pengadil
membuat keputusan, Alice dan Bob sama-sama menang atau kalah bergantung pada sama ada
pasangan jawapan A, B
dianggap betul untuk
pasangan soalan X, Y yang pengadil tanya, dan saya akan cerita sedikit lagi
tentang ni sebentar lagi.
Pertama, jom kita tengak
dengan lebih dekat pada pengadil untuk memahami apa yang
berpotensi mencabar bagi Alice dan Bob dalam permainan bukan tempatan ni.
Dan apa yang buat permainan bukan tempatan
berpotensi mencabar adalah bahawa pengadil boleh guna kerawakan untuk pilih soalan X dan Y.
Itu bermakna Alice
dan Bob ada ketidakpastian, mereka tak tahu terlebih dahulu soalan apa yang akan ditanya kepada mereka, dan mungkin lebih penting,
mereka tak tahu soalan apa
yang orang lagi terima dan ketidakpastian itulah
bersama-sama dengan fakta bahawa mereka tak boleh berkomunikasi
yang menimbulkan cabaran tu.
Jadi, ia serupa dengan situasi di mana detektif
menyoal siasat dua suspek di bilik berbeza, kalau
suspek tu tak tahu
soalan apa yang orang lagi ditanya, ia jauh lebih susah kalau mereka bersalah untuk kekalkan cerita mereka.
Kini, saya sebut sebentar tadi bahawa pengadil membuat penentuan
bahawa Alice dan Bob sama ada menjawab
dengan betul atau silap
bergantung kepada soalan-soalan
yang ditanya kepada mereka.
Diasumsikan bahawa
penentuan ni dibuat mengikut beberapa peraturan tetap dan kamu boleh pertimbangkan mana-mana peraturan yang kamu nak,
tapi apa pun ia,
diasumsikan bahawa Alice
dan Bob tahu peraturan tu, jadi sekurang-kurangnya mereka ada peluang untuk menjawab dengan betul.
Kita akan tengok
peraturan bagi permainan CHSH sebentar, tapi kita boleh
pertimbangkan peraturan berbeza dan kita akan ada contoh berbeza permainan bukan tempatan.
Sesetengah permainan bukan tempatan menarik dan sebenarnya sesetengahnya sangat menarik dan misteri hingga ke hari ini dan
sesetengahnya tak begitu menarik,
itulah je sifat
model permainan bukan tempatan.
Pun begitu, inilah dua perkara berbeza yang diperlukan untuk menerangkan pengadil; betul-betul macam mana soalan-soalan dipilih
dan pasangan jawapan mana yang betul untuk setiap pasangan soalan yang mungkin.
Kalau kita ada huraian
tentang dua perkara tu, maka kita ada huraian bagi pengadil dan itu secara berkesan menerangkan
satu contoh permainan bukan tempatan.
Kini jom kita tengok
permainan CHSH secara khusus.
Cara permainan ni
ditakrifkan atau, sama erti, cara pengadil ditakrifkan adalah seperti berikut;
pertama, seperti yang saya dah sebut, soalan-soalan dan jawapan-jawapan semuanya adalah bit, jadi pengadil hantar bit X
kepada Alice dan bit Y kepada Bob,
dan masing-masing balas dengan satu bit. Alice balas dengan A
dan Bob balas dengan B.
Cara pengadil memilih
soalan mana yang hendak ditanya adalah mudah, dia memilihnya
secara seragam rawak,
jadi, pasangan soalan X, Y adalah sama kemungkinannya untuk menjadi mana-mana
satu daripada empat kemungkinan, sifar sifar, sifar satu,
satu sifar, dan satu satu.
Akhirnya, peraturan yang
menentukan jawapan mana yang menang dan jawapan mana yang kalah adalah
bahawa pasangan jawapan A, B adalah betul untuk pasangan soalan X, Y
WEBVTT
jika dan hanya jika eksklusif atau bagi A dan B adalah sama dengan dan logik bagi X dan Y.
Itu mungkin sedikit lebih mudah dicerna kalau kita ungkapkan syarat-syarat tu
dalam bentuk jadual seperti yang kamu nampak di sini.
Dalam lajur pertama, kita ada empat pasangan soalan yang mungkin, dan dalam lajur kedua kita
ada syarat-syarat ke atas A dan B
yang diperlukan untuk
Alice dan Bob menang.
Dalam tiga kes pertama,
dan bagi A dan Y adalah sifar, jadi eksklusif atau mestilah sama dengan sifar
supaya mereka menang,
dan itu sama je dengan mengatakan A dan B mestilah sama kerana A dan B adalah bit,
dan kes keempat,
dan bagi X dan Y adalah sama
dengan satu dan jadi eksklusif atau bagi A dan B mestilah sama dengan satu supaya Alice dan Bob menang
dan itu sama je
dengan mengatakan A dan B mestilah berbeza.
Jadi, itulah permainan CHSH, dan kini kita boleh fikirkan
strategi-strategi yang berbeza yang mungkin untuk Alice dan Bob dan seberapa baik mereka boleh buat dalam permainan ni.
Jom mulakan dengan memikirkan tentang
strategi deterministik di mana jawapan A Alice adalah satu
fungsi soalan X yang dia terima, dan
begitu juga, jawapan B Bob
adalah fungsi
soalan Y yang dia terima.
Dan rupanya, tiada
strategi deterministik yang boleh menang setiap kali.
Satu cara untuk hujahkan tu adalah
dengan hanya pergi satu persatu melalui semua strategi deterministik yang mungkin dan semak bahawa setiap satu daripadanya kalah
untuk sekurang-kurangnya satu daripada empat
pasangan soalan yang mungkin.
Alice dan Bob, masing-masing ada
empat fungsi yang mungkin untuk dipilih, kita nampak keempat-empat fungsi tu dalam pelajaran satu, jadi ada 16 kemungkinan
untuk disemak keseluruhannya.
Cara lain untuk nampak tu adalah nak
fikirkan tentang persamaan-persamaan di sini pada skrin, kita memikirkan tentang strategi deterministik
di mana A dan B adalah fungsi
X dan Y masing-masing.
Jadi sebagai contoh, A bagi sifar
mewakili jawapan Alice bila soalan X miliknya sama dengan sifar dan a bagi satu mewakili jawapan Alice
bila soalan X miliknya sama dengan satu.
Inilah empat persamaan
yang mesti benar supaya syarat-syarat kemenangan dipenuhi dalam setiap empat kes.
Sebagai contoh, kalau X sama dengan
sifar dan Y sama dengan sifar, maka eksklusif atau bagi A
dan B mestilah sama dengan sifar,
sedangkan dalam kes di mana X sama dengan satu dan Y sama dengan satu,
eksklusif atau bagi A dan B mestilah sama dengan satu.
Satu cara untuk nampak bahawa
tiada cara untuk pilih fungsi A dan B supaya
persamaan-persamaan ni semua benar, adalah dengan hanya ambil eksklusif atau semua persamaan tu.
Eksklusif atau mana-mana
nilai binari dengan dirinya sendiri adalah sama dengan sifar, dan jadi ia mengikut bahawa eksklusif atau
bahagian kiri
adalah sama dengan sifar, itu
kerana kita ada dua kejadian a sifar, dua kejadian a satu,
dua kejadian B sifar
dan dua kejadian B satu.
Jadi, dengan xor semua bersama
memberikan kita jawapan akhir sifar, tapi kalau kita ambil eksklusif atau bahagian kanan persamaan-persamaan tu,
kita dapat satu bukan sifar. Jadi empat persamaan tu
tak mungkin semua benar, sekurang-kurangnya satu daripadanya mestilah salah
dan itu akan mengakibatkan
kerugian bagi Alice dan Bob dalam sekurang-kurangnya satu daripada empat kes.
Dan jadi ia mengikut kerana pengadil memilih soalan-soalan secara seragam bahawa kebarangkalian Alice dan Bob menang
menggunakan strategi deterministik
adalah paling banyak tiga per empat atau 75%.
Fakta bahawa Alice dan Bob boleh menang dengan kebarangkalian tiga per empat sebenarnya cukup mudah untuk nampak,
kalau Alice dan Bob keduanya menjawab sifar sepanjang masa, misalnya,
mereka akan betul tiga
daripada empat kali.
Jadi Alice dan Bob tak dapat
buat lebih baik daripada menang 75% daripada masa menggunakan strategi deterministik.
Tapi macam mana pula strategi probabilistik?
Nah, rupanya menggunakan
strategi probabilistik tak dapat bantu mereka sama sekali, itu kerana setiap
strategi probabilistik
boleh secara alternatif dilihat
sebagai pemilihan rawak strategi deterministik sama seperti operasi probabilistik boleh dilihat
sebagai pemilihan rawak
operasi deterministik, seperti yang kita nampak dalam pelajaran pertama.
Purata tak pernah
lebih besar daripada maksimum, jadi ia mengikut bahawa strategi probabilistik tak menawarkan kelebihan
dalam hal memenangi
berbanding strategi deterministik. Ini termasuk pun kemungkinan bahawa pilihan rawak Alice dan Bob berkorelasi.
Jadi, kesimpulannya ialah menang dengan kebarangkalian tiga per empat adalah yang terbaik yang Alice
dan Bob mungkin boleh buat menggunakan sebarang strategi klasikal,
sama ada deterministik
atau probabilistik.
Soalan semula jadi yang perlu ditanya pada masa ni ialah sama ada Alice dan Bob boleh buat lebih baik menggunakan strategi kuantum,
dan khususnya
kalau mereka berkongsi keadaan kuantum terbelit yang mereka boleh sediakan
sebelum memainkan permainan, boleh itu bantu mereka?
Jawapannya ialah ya, boleh, dan itulah tujuan contoh ni dan itulah sebabnya ia sangat menarik.
Jadi jom kita tengok betul-betul macam mana
Alice dan Bob boleh buat lebih baik dalam permainan ni menggunakan entanglement.
WEBVTT
Perkara pertama yang perlu kita buat adalah mentakrifkan vektor keadaan kuantum Chi
theta untuk setiap sudut theta, seperti yang kamu nampak di sini pada skrin.
Jadi, Chi theta adalah sama dengan
kosinus theta darab ket sifar tambah sinus theta darab ket
satu, dan di sini ngomong-ngomong,
kita memikirkan tentang
sudut dalam sebutan radian.
Jadi sebagai contoh, berikut adalah vektor yang kita dapat bila theta sama dengan pi per
empat, iaitu 45 darjah.
Kosinus pi per empat
dan sinus pi per empat keduanya sama dengan satu per
punca dua, jadi ini hanyalah nama lain untuk keadaan plus.
Berikut adalah contoh lain bila theta sama dengan tiga kali pi per lapan, dan kalau kamu tak
kebetulan tahu sinus
dan kosinus tiga kali pi per lapan terus daripada kepala,
berikut adalah jadual nilai-nilai sinus dan kosinus yang kita
sebenarnya akan perlukan
sepanjang contoh ni
dan termasuk yang kita perlukan untuk vektor tertentu ni.
Kini, kalau kita nak ambil hasil darab dalam antara mana-mana dua vektor ni
untuk sudut-sudut, alpha dan beta katakan, ia
mudah untuk buat tu.
Kita hanya ada entri nombor nyata
dalam vektor-vektor ni jadi tiada
konjugat kompleks yang perlu dikhuatiri dan kita dapat hasil darab kosinus-kosinus
tambah hasil darab sinus-sinus, dan kita boleh guna salah satu
daripada rumus penambahan sudut yang dipanggil
untuk menyederhanakan tu, ia adalah
kosinus bagi perbezaan antara sudut-sudut dan
kerana fungsi kosinus
adalah simetri di sekitar sifar,
sebenarnya tak kira susunan mana kita ambilnya.
Kalau kamu tak hafal identiti trigonometri seperti ni
ngomong-ngomong, kamu tak keseorangan, tapi kamu tak perlu ingatnya,
kamu boleh cari je. Yang ni memang masuk akal
walaupun bila kamu fikirkan tentang tafsiran geometri hasil darab dalam
antara vektor unit nyata sebagai kosinus sudut antara mereka.
Kalau kita kira hasil darab dalam
daripada hasil darab tensor mana-mana dua vektor ni
dengan keadaan Phi plus, kita dapat ungkapan yang nampak serupa
kecuali ada punca
dua dalam penyebutnya.
Ini adalah kali pertama
keadaan Phi plus muncul dalam konteks
contoh ni ngomong-ngomong, dan kita akan nampak betul-betul kenapa kita berminat
dengan hasil darab dalam tertentu ni tak lama lagi, tapi buat masa ni jom
kita perhatikan sahaja bahawa kita dapat ungkapan yang sama yang kita ada
untuk hasil darab dalam dibahagi
dengan punca dua dan jadi kita boleh sederhanakan seperti tadi.
Seterusnya, kita akan takrifkan
matriks unitari, U theta, untuk setiap sudut theta
seperti yang kamu nampak di sini,
ia tak sukar untuk
semak bahawa ini memang matriks unitari.
Perkara utama yang perlu kita
kenal pasti adalah bahawa vektor si theta berortogon kepada
vektor si theta tambah pi per dua, dan itu masuk akal
kerana kalau kita pusing sebanyak pi per dua, iaitu 90 darjah, kita
mendapat vektor yang berortogon.
Kalau kita kemudian darabkan U
theta dengan U theta dagger, kita dapat matriks identiti.
Secara intuitif,
apa yang matriks ini buat sebagai operasi adalah
memetakan si theta kepada ket sifar dan si theta tambah pi dua kepada ket satu.
Pada masa ni, kita ada
semua yang kita perlukan untuk menerangkan strategi Alice dan Bob.
Pertama, sama seperti yang kita ada untuk teleportation dan superdense coding, Alice dan Bob akan mulakan dengan berkongsi e-bit.
Alice pegang qubit A,
Bob pegang qubit B, dan bersama-sama dua qubit tu
berada dalam keadaan Phi plus.
Tindakan Alice adalah seperti berikut; dia tengok bit X yang
dia terima daripada pengadil,
dan kalau X sama dengan sifar,
dia lakukan U sifar ke atas A, yang kebetulan adalah
sama dengan tidak buat apa-apa kerana U sifar adalah matriks identiti,
kalau X sama dengan satu sebaliknya, dia kenakan U pi per empat kepada A.
Selepas dia kenakan salah satu
daripada dua operasi tu, dia ukur A menggunakan
pengukuran asas piawai dan hantar apa jua hasil yang
dia dapat kepada pengadil.
Bob buat sesuatu yang sangat serupa, qubit miliknya dipanggil B sudah tentu, dan dia terima Y daripada
pengadil berbanding X
tapi perbezaan utama adalah
bahawa dia guna sudut-sudut berbeza untuk operasi unitari miliknya.
Kalau Y sama dengan sifar, dia
kenakan U pi per lapan, dan kalau Y sama dengan satu, dia kenakan u negatif pi per lapan.
Dan kita akan nampak kenapa pilihan sudut-sudut ni adalah pilihan yang bagus tak lama lagi,
ia langsung tak jelas.
Dan berikut adalah rajah circuit
yang mengungkapkan strategi ni.
Bob berada di atas dan Alice
berada di bawah kali ni, berikut adalah e-bit yang sedang masuk
dan inilah gate-gate unitari
yang Alice dan Bob mungkin atau mungkin tidak kenakan
bergantung kepada apa X dan Y.
Untuk yang ni dan yang ni, kita ada gate yang dikawal sama ada oleh bit X atau oleh bit Y
dan untuk dua ni di sini, kita ada apa yang nampak macam
gate kawalan kecuali bulatannya tak diisi.
Dan apa ni bermaksud adalah
bahawa kalau bit kawalan ditetapkan kepada sifar, maka gate dilakukan dan kalau kawalan ditetapkan kepada
satu, maka tiada apa yang berlaku.
Jadi, ia adalah sama seperti
gate kawalan biasa kecuali peranan sifar dan satu untuk kawalan ditukar.
Jadi, secara berkesan, Bob
lakukan gate ni kalau Y sama dengan sifar, dia
lakukan gate ni
WEBVTT
kalau Y sama dengan satu, dan begitu juga, Alice lakukan gate ni
kalau X sama dengan sifar, dan gate ni,
kalau X sama dengan satu.
Jadi, itulah strategi Alice dan Bob dan kini kita hanya perlu
cari tahu seberapa baik ia berjaya.
Untuk analisis strategi kuantum yang baru saya terangkan, kita
sebenarnya hanya perlukan dua perkara pada masa ni, pertama, matriks unitari U Theta
adalah seperti yang kamu nampak di sini, dan
kedua kita ada rumus ni.
Kita sebenarnya tak perlukan pun definisi vektor si theta lagi, dua persamaan ni adalah semua yang kita perlukan.
Ada empat kes yang perlu
dipertimbangkan bermula dengan kes satu, iaitu X sama dengan
sifar dan Y sama dengan sifar.
Dan kalau kita tengok kembali strategi tu, kita akan dapati bahawa dalam kes
ini Alice lakukan U sifar ke atas qubit miliknya dan Bob lakukan
U pi per lapan ke atas qubit miliknya.
Ingat, Alice berada di
bawah dan Bob berada di atas, jadi keadaan yang mereka
dapat kelihatan seperti ini.
Dan dengan mengembangkan tu
mengikut definisi U theta, kita dapat
ungkapan yang kamu nampak di sini.
Kita tak perlu mengembangkannya
lebih lanjut kerana kita ada
rumus yang lain untuk membantu kita.
Dan kalau kita kenakan rumus tu
untuk setiap empat sebutan, apa yang kita dapat adalah ini.
Pada masa ni Alice dan Bob keduanya ukur dan berikut adalah jadual yang
menerangkan taburan hasil-hasilnya.
Kita ambil nilai mutlak
kuasa dua pekali-pekali untuk mendapat kebarangkalian, yang kebetulan adalah
kuasa dua pekali-pekali tu
kerana pekali-pekaliny adalah
semua nombor nyata dalam kes ni.
Kalau kita guna nilai-nilai
sinus dan kosinus dari awal pelajaran tadi
bersama-sama dengan beberapa simetri, kita boleh ungkapkan kebarangkalian-kebarangkalian ni
seperti yang kita ada di sini
dalam lajur terakhir.
Kini, apa yang kita betul-betul ambil berat
ialah kebarangkalian mereka menang, dan ingat bahawa, dalam kes X dan Y keduanya sifar,
mereka menang kalau A dan B sama dan mereka kalah kalau A dan B tidak sama.
Kalau kita kira kebarangkalian-kebarangkalian tu, kita dapati bahawa kebarangkalian
bahawa A dan B sama adalah jumlah nombor ni dan nombor ni,
yang sama dengan dua tambah
punca dua kesemuanya per empat, iaitu kira-kira 85%.
Kebarangkalian bahawa A dan B tidak sama adalah dua tolak punca dua kesemuanya per empat, yang secara semula jadinya adalah satu tolak kuantiti
yang baru kita kira, jadi
mereka menang dengan kebarangkalian kira-kira 85% dalam kes ni.
Ada tiga kes lagi untuk dipertimbangkan, tapi semuanya sangat serupa dengan yang ini,
dalam kes di mana X sama dengan
sifar dan Y sama dengan satu, Bob kenakan U negatif pi per lapan dan bukannya U pi per lapan,
nilai-nilai dalam
rumus-rumus berubah sedikit, tapi kita berakhir dengan tepat
kebarangkalian yang sama yang kita ada dalam kes sebelumnya.
Bila X sama dengan sifar dan Y sama dengan satu, Alice dan Bob masih menang
bila A dan B sama dan jadi kita ada tepat kebarangkalian menang yang sama
seperti tadi.
Dalam kes ketiga, bila X sama dengan satu dan Y sama dengan sifar, kita
ada situasi yang serupa, sudut-sudutnya berbeza,
tapi mereka ada tepat
hubungan yang sama antara
satu sama lain, dan sebenarnya, kita memang dapat tepat
vektor yang sama yang kita dapat dalam kes sebelumnya.
Jadi kebarangkalian-kebarangkaliannya sama dan begitu juga kebarangkalian menangnnya.
Kes terakhir adalah sedikit
berbeza seperti yang mungkin kita jangkakan kerana syarat kemenangan
adalah berbeza dalam kes ni.
Bila X dan Y keduanya sama dengan satu, Alice dan Bob menang bila
A dan B berbeza.
Kaedah asasnya sama, walaupun sudut-sudutnya berbeza, kali ni, kita dapat vektor ini di sini
dan kamu boleh semak tu dengan melalui penolakan-penolakan yang diperlukan.
Kebarangkalian-kebarangkalian memang berubah akhirnya, dan kalau kita cari nilai-nilai yang kita perlukan, kita nampak bahawa kebarangkalian-kebarangkaliannya secara berkesan
telah bertukar kedudukan dari tadi, jadi kali ini ialah kebarangkalian
bahawa A tidak sama dengan B, yang merupakan yang lebih besar daripada dua,
tapi itu bagus kerana dalam kes ni, Alice dan Bob menang bila
A dan B tidak sama.
Jadi sekali lagi, mereka menang dengan
kebarangkalian lebih kurang 85%.
Memandangkan mereka menang dalam setiap
kes dengan kebarangkalian yang sama, iaitu dua tambah punca dua
kesemuanya per empat atau lebih kurang 85%,
itulah kebarangkalian
mereka menang keseluruhannya.
Itu lebih baik daripada mana-mana strategi klasikal yang boleh buat untuk permainan ni, dan itulah
yang membuatnya menarik.
Ini kebetulan adalah
kebarangkalian menang yang optimum untuk mana-mana strategi kuantum, kamu
tak boleh buat lebih baik daripada ni menggunakan mana-mana keadaan terbelit.
Fakta tu dikenali sebagai ketaksamaan Tsirelson, ia dinamakan sempena Boris
Tsirelson yang pertama kali membuktikannya, dan setahu saya adalah
salah seorang daripada orang pertama
yang menggambarkan contoh ni sebagai permainan. Kalau analisis
yang baru kita lalui nampak sedikit misteri,
adalah mungkin untuk memikirkan
tentangnya secara geometri, yang mungkin berguna untuk
beri kamu gambaran yang lebih baik tentang pilihan sudut-sudut tu.
Khususnya, kalau kita guna
rumus yang kamu nampak di sini, yang boleh kita simpulkan dengan mudah
daripada ungkapan-ungkapan
yang kita dah jumpa untuk
hasil darab dalam yang terlibat, maka kita boleh secara alternatif
ungkapkan kebarangkalian hasil-hasil pengukuran yang berbeza
WEBVTT
dalam empat kes seperti berikut; pertama, kalau X, Y sama dengan sifar, sifar, maka inilah kebarangkalian
pelbagai hasil pengukuran, dan kamu perlu sama ada fikirkan kembali atau tengok kembali analisis
yang baru kita lalui untuk simpulkan tu menggunakan rumus kita.
Di sini, kita boleh nampak
vektor-vektor keadaan yang berbeza dilukis seperti tadi, dan kod warna di sini
ialah biru sepadan
dengan hasil sifar dan merah
sepadan dengan hasil satu.
Kamu boleh nampak bahawa sudut
antara vektor-vektor biru dan sudut antara vektor-vektor merah
adalah agak kecil,
ia pi per lapan dalam kedua-dua kes, jadi kosinusnya agak besar, dan itu bermakna bahawa kebarangkalian dua hasil tu
adalah sama adalah agak besar.
Dalam kes di mana X, Y sama dengan sifar, satu, ia adalah situasi yang serupa, sudut-sudut antara vektor-vektor yang mempunyai warna yang sama adalah kecil,
jadi kebarangkalian
hasil yang sama adalah, sekali lagi, agak besar.
Kes ketiga adalah serupa, dan dalam kes keempat
bila X, Y sama dengan satu, satu, sesuatu yang menarik berlaku,
kali ini, hanya dengan cara
vektor-vektor ni telah dipilih, kita nampak bahawa sudut-sudut antara
vektor-vektor yang mempunyai warna yang sama
adalah agak besar, dan khususnya sudut-sudutnya adalah tiga kali
pi per lapan dalam kedua-dua kes.
Ini bermakna bahawa kebarangkalian
hasil pengukurannya sama adalah agak kecil, tapi ini adalah satu-satunya kes
di mana Alice dan Bob menang
bila jawapan mereka berbeza,
jadi itulah yang kita nak.
Sekali lagi, berikut adalah vektor-vektor: bila X, Y sama dengan sifar, sifar,
bila X, Y sama dengan sifar, satu,
bila X, Y sama dengan satu, sifar,
dan bila X, Y sama dengan satu, satu.
Dan mungkin gambar geometri ni berguna dalam membina sedikit intuisi
tentang cara strategi ni berjaya
dan kenapa pelbagai sudut ni dipilih dengan cara yang mereka pilih.
Untuk menghabiskan pelajaran ni, saya akan buat beberapa komen ringkas
tentang permainan CHSH.
Pertama, seperti yang saya dah sebut, contoh ni tak selalu
digambarkan sebagai permainan.
Dalam komuniti fizik, misalnya, ia lebih biasa bahawa
contoh tu digambarkan hanya sebagai eksperimen dan bukannya permainan
dan Alice dan Bob dilihat
sebagai pengesan dan bukannya pemain.
Idea asas eksperimen seperti ni di mana entanglement membawa
kepada keputusan statistik yang tidak konsisten dengan
mana-mana huraian klasikal
atau lebih umumnya mana-mana
teori berdasarkan pemboleh ubah tersembunyi tempatan yang dipanggil,
adalah oleh John Bell, eponymous keadaan Bell,
dan jadi orang sering merujuk
kepada eksperimen jenis ni sebagai ujian Bell.
Kadang-kadang orang juga
merujuk kepada teorem Bell, yang boleh diformulasikan dalam pelbagai cara, tapi ia pada dasarnya mengatakan bahawa mekanik kuantum
tidak serasi dengan teori pemboleh ubah tersembunyi tempatan yang dipanggil.
Permainan atau ketaksamaan CHSH adalah pada dasarnya contoh ujian Bell yang sangat cantik dan bersih,
dan kamu boleh fikirkan
contoh ni sebagai bukti atau demonstrasi teorem Bell.
Komen kedua ialah permainan CHSH memberi kita satu cara untuk menguji secara eksperimen bahawa teori maklumat kuantum
adalah teori yang tepat. Kita sebenarnya boleh sediakan eksperimen yang melaksanakan permainan CHSH,
termasuk jenis
strategi berdasarkan entanglement yang baru saya gambarkan, dan
tengok kalau ia berjaya, dan ia memang berjaya.
Ini memberi kita
tahap keyakinan yang tinggi bahawa entanglement adalah nyata, dan tidak seperti cara
yang mungkin samar atau puitis
yang kita cuba gunakan
untuk menerangkan entanglement, permainan atau eksperimen CHSH
memberi kita cara yang konkrit
dan boleh diuji untuk memerhati entanglement.
Kalau tu kedengaran penting,
ia memang penting, dan Hadiah Nobel 2022
dalam fizik mengakui tepat ini.
Hadiah tu diberikan kepada
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, yang merupakan C dalam CHSH, dan Anton Zeilinger
untuk eksperimen dengan foton terbelit yang mewujudkan pelanggaran
ketaksamaan Bell, atau dalam erti kata lain, yang
menunjukkan bahawa strategi kuantum
seperti yang saya gambarkan sebenarnya berjaya dan mengatasi strategi klasikal.
Dan kalau kamu berminat untuk
ketahui lebih lanjut tentang ni, saya menggalakkan kamu tengok
video tentang Teorem Bell oleh rakan sekerja saya Olivia Lanes,
di sini di saluran YouTube Qiskit.
Dan akhirnya, topik
permainan bukan tempatan secara lebih umum adalah benar-benar menarik, dan ia adalah
kawasan penyelidikan yang aktif
yang mempertemukan
fizik, sains komputer, dan matematik tulen dan masih ada banyak soalan-soalan menarik
tentang permainan bukan tempatan yang
masih belum terjawab hingga ke hari ini.
Dan itulah pengakhiran pelajaran empat, serta pengakhiran
unit satu siri tentang Asas Maklumat Kuantum.
Pelajaran pertama menerangkan
cara maklumat kuantum berfungsi untuk sistem tunggal dalam pengasingan, dan pelajaran kedua menerangkan cara maklumat kuantum
berfungsi untuk sistem berbilang,
yang agak semula jadi muncul daripada cara ia berfungsi untuk sistem tunggal.
WEBVTT
Pelajaran ketiga memperkenalkan
model quantum circuit bagi pengiraan, dan dalam pelajaran keempat, kita tengok tiga contoh penting
yang menggambarkan benda-benda yang
boleh kita buat dengan entanglement.
Dalam perjalanan tu, kita nampak beberapa konsep matematik yang sangat penting,
termasuk hasil darab tensor dan hasil darab dalam, dan kita perhatikan
beberapa had asasi
maklumat kuantum.
Saya harap kamu akan ikut saya untuk
unit seterusnya siri ni, yang akan berkenaan algoritma kuantum, di mana kita akan fokus pada soalan
tentang apakah kelebihan pengiraan
yang ditawarkan maklumat kuantum.
Selamat tinggal sampai jumpa lagi.